there are four people in this painting
three of them are made out of paint the
fourth is the paint interior of a
kitchen was painted in 1815 and like
many paintings from that time one of the
colors used in it was mummy Brown a
pigment literally made from the ground
up dried flesh of ancient mummies today
we Hollow mummies as fragile time
capsules but in the 1700s there was a
thriving mummy trade between Egypt and
Europe ground up mummy was believed to
have Mystic healing powers and the oil
paints that could be made from it were
highly valued so mummy Brown was used in
countless paintings for hundreds of
years it wasn't until the late 1800s
that people began to really question its
use the dwindling supply of mummies
didn't help either and so it began to
fall out of fashion the people who were
turned into paint didn't ask to be what
they wanted was immortality and they may
have got what they wanted but they also
got an afterlife they didn't expect not
one for their personal Souls but one for
the anonymous beauty of the rotten tari
Darkness anyone can become
[Music]